I would like all government sort of arms
whether it's education the police the
NHS the Judiciary as a whole I would
like all of them to get out of the
business of telling women what we can
and cannot say and I would like them to
stop indoctrinating children and I would
like them to stop you know the police
I've been involved with the police on
five occasions now over this issue I
would like the police to be totally
neutral again and we stop telling these
lies I would like the gra to have
evaporated Into Thin Air and that people
are embarrassed to ever say they
endorsed it and Lobby groups and and
money out of government
so it's just simple I just would like to
get back to a place of Common Sense and
Truth
which maybe we were never there but I
didn't know about it so back to the
point where uh women could say a woman
is an adult human female without fearing
some sort of Retribution